And when you finally get his life
in the big time,
when you think back when you're driving that Budweiser truck,
I just,
ah,
I appreciate every job that I had.
You know,
I appreciate every,
everything that,
you know,
that it happened to me in my life.
It May,
it allowed me to appreciate,
you know,
who I am now allowed me to appreciate just the smaller things.
It allowed me to just be myself.
You know,
I'm a type of person that I don't really care about fame.
I don't even want to be called the celebrity.
You know what I mean?
I want to be able to live my life and do what I do.
I want to be able to enjoy just the smallest things in life.
I don't want people to take that away from me.
You know what I mean?
Being able to go to a movie or a grocery store or whatever,
spend time with the family you can't shut.
Cause I like cooking.
I like going to the grocery stores,
the fresh market,
pick up my fruit and stuff that I want to put in my whatever I'm preparing for
the night and stuff like that.
And I'm a people's person as well,
so I don't mind being bothered,
but you know,
it can't get crate.
I've seen other people get it get crazy for an iron man,
you know?
And they said it themselves like they don't,
they wished that they could do certain things,
normal things,
but people,
people,
people take it to the next level,
you know,
get all in your bit.
Especially after this fight.
Like I didn't had to cut some people,
you know,
I didn't have to cut some people because they attentions was already wrong.
They seen the potential.
I put,
they seen the opportunity and they tried to make moves on me,
you know,
already,
and different things.
That's why I said lonely at the top,
you know,
because you get to the point where you don't know who to trust.
You start down everybody around you.
You know,
I'm an energy person so I'm always re refreshing the feeling of the energy.
Let me see what it feels like.
You know what I'm saying?
None of that.
I always allow me to meet certain people to be around certain people because if
you change your presence,
the energy just to just,
it would change as well.
It changes.
It shifts the way you feel when you're around.
Then all of a sudden you feel like they're looking for angles and trying to
profit off of you.
They're trying to get you to do things.
Yes.
You know,
Eh,
you know,
I'm a,
I'm a strong minded person.
I got a lot of strong minded men around me.
I always tell people we speak positive,
we think positive and we surround ourselves by positive,
you know,
positive energy,
and then I will,
results is always positive.
The only time you ever see me,
you know,
acting out,
I would say if someone would come and break that piece,
you'll never find me and my brothers,
you know,
out and you know,
mess with someone's starting anything.
I'm not a,
I'm not,
I'm not the one that started anything because I want peace.
I don't even want to see a fight outside.
If it's not in the boxing ring,
I'll walk away if I see it on the outside because I feel like they don't know
what they're doing.
You know what I mean?
It's then something could happen easily.
You see guns being pulled out now a days and you know,
any little thing.
So I started to stay away from confrontation much as possible.
That's why I think God it on my home body,
you know,
if I'm not here,
I'm at home,
you know,
because they say when you had to find,
I mean you had to,
you know,
find things to do and you had to leave home all the time.
You don't have a peaceful home.
And um,
I believe in that,
you know,
I don't understand when you're,
when it's busy,
you have to work and stuff.
That's one thing.
But you know,
when you just said,
man,
let's go here.
Let's go ahead and do it.
See,
I don't want to,
I don't,
I don't put myself out there to be a risk for no one.
You know,
my risk is at home.
If something's going to happen,
then you know the was at home.
You know,
I don't,
I don't put myself out there to have chance chances at the chances of where
people look down and it's like,
Hey,
let's do this.
Let's do that to him.
Or I tried to,
because I know what I'm capable of doing.
You know what I mean?
And I like being me.
I just like being laid back down to Earth,
get along with everyone.
I'm a people's person and a lot of people would never know it because they only
see the perspective of me and the ring.
Or they see me on youtube and those interviews,
yes,
you're a very mellow guy.
Like right now,
I'm sure I'm a lay.
I'm just,
I'm the coolest.
I'm the best.